foreign
[Music]
which brings us to our current exhibit
the mythical staff of the Gods in
Homer's Tale the staff was said to
harness the gift of all gods
oh
welcome proud soldiers what did I say
museums are fun amusement parks for the
brains okay
reason to get pushy everyone will get a
chance to see it
carved from a Heartwood not seen in over
2 000 years the two halves of this
ancient replica were recently discovered
in of all places a waste processing
plant outside of Philadelphia so strong
they reportedly broke three trash
compactors
okay wow friends that's enough I'm sort
of the star of the show here stop
stop
[Music]
foreign
yes
[Music]
foreign
please just let me go
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
foreign
s are fun
[Music]
let's have more of it we can do nothing
while the staff remained sundered
the champions of this realm outnumber us
human champion
he will have chosen with meticulous
Precision the strongest most keenly
intelligent Champions this realm has
ever witnessed I'm an idiot
I don't deserve these Powers if I'm
being honest like what am I even
contributing there's already a superhero
with a red suit with a lightning bolt on
it and I'm fast but he's faster Aquaman
is literally huge and he's so manly and
Batman is so cool and I'm just me and I
can't say this to anyone else because my
family looks to me as a leader but I
feel like
a fraud you understand I'm a
pediatrician right
I mean yeah well you were you were
recommended by another patient Billy
Batson it doesn't matter can you help
fix my thoughts so that they just like
you know stop happening all right look
and again pediatrician not a
psychiatrist but it sounds to me like
you're experiencing imposter syndrome
and often that originates from trauma
early in life so if you don't mind me
asking
how well do you remember your childhood
like it was today
trauma uh I don't know I mean I never
met my dad uh my mom abandoned me at a
Christmas Carnival I spent a lot of time
in the Foster system ran away from 11
homes got into a lot of fights then it
was abducted by a wizard who gave me
superpowers and then dude just like died
in front of my face that's not a small
amount Dr contracted seven demons and
held my whole family hostage so we had
to rip out one of his eyeballs and then
everybody got super powers but now
everyone's kind of like doing their own
thing and I'm the only one trying to
keep everybody together okay okay well
let's just process that
right rejected by your parents then by
the system and now rejected by a city
you try to protect I never said I was
rejected by my city
rejected by city that's the tribunal
nobody reads the Tribune I do anyway
okay well um I appreciate your help but
I got some real problems there's this
terrorist hostage situation going on so
hostage situation yeah
why do we always have to play war games
hey it's practice for other job
each with us
with us I know how it sounds but the
house keeps getting struck by lightning
Leo I'm telling you besides you're the
one always talking about teamwork but we
don't need guns
why were there Skittles in my pockets it
was supposed to be a surprise it was
she's very moody lately why do you think
I put Skittles in her pocket
because it's an army of unicorns killing
Genghis Khan yes
yes corns aren't real it's
cumulative history
[Music]
yes I told you you would get into it if
you give it a chance yeah I'm really
starting to see the appeal
all units that
it's crazy music Freddy it is isn't it
very urgent Melody too we should see it
perform live I was thinking the same
thing I feel like we can get tickets to
that concert too maybe not six all or
none that's the rule yet I'm still gonna
walk backwards now so now this lasts and
final chance Billy Batson come with me
no no no no no no no no no no no no man
it sure is a beautiful day in
Philadelphia
is it though almost finished again okay
this better be good
whoa whoa
where's everyone going
to fight crime
okay bye mom my mom Bye Mom bye bye Rosa
give it time
you guys ready